welcome to this video playing Jimmy the
saint from Egypt it's very tricky to
spot that there is this and i'm not sure
what it is actually in the middle of the
flag so i keep thinking that this is
this is the netherlands okay um no name
i played in two times fifty percent
score okay actually i played again the
a6 line which is of course perfectly
okay it's my the land that I've playing
for years but I actually wanted to try
out the Berlin a couple of times I know
you might fall asleep but it's simply a
good opening he played with d3 this kind
of slow slower Rui not bad so played
many times by top players it's one of
those lines that is directed against the
Marshall attack well I wasn't intending
to to play it but in the top level chest
the the marshal is really am very common
and white really does not show much
against it
a fire flow and interesting so what
exactly is the point why can I not take
a five the next move not quite sure 97
nurse maybe 95 and still I could take
that not sure I'd rather take it with
the night on c8 before I can just take
twice I get a 5 here
hmm
yeah well maybe
Jim
now maybe this is too risky I don't know
but I mean it's a case of having said a
million you need to say be as well how
to turn back now from this idea but it
gives white some obvious compensation I
mean you just blundered the porn of
course but it is some compensation
because of the central the central
dominance that white has those two
nights are quite something yeah let's
create some it is risky but I played
getting taking the pawn can get this
back be successor of course may be a
dangerous option but okay I cannot leave
the night on a five it's always very
light and a big liability needing the
protection from the Queen on d aid one
problem is I cannot take on e5 easily
s95 always allow since the night coming
to c 6 mhm well maybe I'm we need to
actually allow it and don't don't know
yeah it is dangerous but okay I need to
take it's not much not much choice and
after the capture this 95 Wow and this
is super dangerous
yes super dangerous is putting it mildly
I cannot take on d5 sp7 hangs I need to
play that well now then then what then
it's a very bad position yeah scott
takes Bishop g5 after all kinds of stuff
yeah very ugly I hoped maybe that I can
use to look on the on the seventh-ranked
check oh I forgot about that move at all
okay and was it was probably a loss
anyway let this was this was probably
too dangerous to take on a five in that
in that manner esox is is just just that
it's too much I cannot do that yeah so
maybe even okay this of course has some
direct consequences for the evaluation
this means that night c 8 is nonsense
the only idea of putting the night on c
8 is free to grab the pawn and yeah Wow
okay theoretically speaking i can still
refrain from doing that like taking
taking here twice but I don't put the
night on CA to open up the position that
this is clear so I must go here taking
it was really too much and now night d
five probably now now the four is it's
not not dangerous at all i can just take
here a couple of times and then I'm
totally fine 95 is of course those after
which this is the house but here of
course I don't need to take I can play
all kinds of moves 96 for example
putting some pressure on d5 yeah this is
this is ok I mean I was just too greedy
I wanted to get this pawn and it says
it's too dangerous after define this is
this is too much already this is too
much probably I mean 9 p-7 wasn't a good
defense
of course he sixes it's like killing me
immediately after that charm a mean I'd
c4 or something but yeah it's already
very ugly what I need to do is simply
and put put the night on 27 after which
is not clear what a 5 a-5 a4 a5 really
what it did what it did for his chances
I mean here taking I don't know this is
this is very in some very awkward pieces
but okay well as this is may be playable
it still may be playable it looks a bit
ugly but it's not his he does not have
the central steamroller like in the game
and this is just not playable alright a
good game by white thanks for watching